In this lesson, we're going to go and take a look at the outline for this course overall,
and then we're going to go ahead and take a look at the concept of priority areas when
working with foliage as well as a bit of optimization.
So let's get started.
So one of the first things we'll talk about is foliage optimization, and what that includes
is analyzing scenes and priority areas, one of the most important things that you need
to bring to light, when it comes to your shots, your scene, or interactivity.
One will look at optimization based on shots, lumen updates with foliage, and foliage and
world partition.
Finally, we'll take a look at Niagara optimizations.
From there, we'll look at the checklist for performance, debugging, additional steps,
console commands, FX Outliner, and bacon effects via a foot book as an option.
So let's go and dive right in.
So one of the first things we'll talk about here is foliage optimization.
Rating your scenes and priority areas, I cannot emphasize enough, is very important.
But one of the first things you do need to determine is exactly what your rendering type
is going to be, what you're going to be using for your interactivity, whether you're going
to be using ICVFX or film or interactivity for a game.
This is really up to you, but you need to choose between ray tracing, big lighting, or
lumen.
Now when it comes to ray tracing, you're going to have to handle your frames carefully because
well, the higher you go, using such things as brute force, things are going to slow down
a bit, which we've talked about in previous classes.
When it comes to bake lighting, you need to understand that your reflectivity will not
be accurate unless you're using certain particular tools, maybe even some plugins that are not
inherently on by default.
But they still may not capture the realism that you need and want, and it doesn't update
on the fly.
Lumen allows you to have realistic reflectivity, and it allows you to have updates on the fly,
but at the same time, there is a bit of noise because lumen is still evolving.
So you have to decide your look based on your needs.
So overall, the games workflow is similar to the film workflow, but is a bit more determinant
on whether or where you are in the world, where you're positioned.
So you have to figure that out, and you have to decide where your player is going to go.
In the case of ICVFX, we need to decide where a camera is going to be showing or pointing
at, and how much movement is in that camera.
Is this a still shot?
Do we need the camera to switch to a different angle in the middle of the actors on stage?
This is really things you need to consider.
For foliage, determine how much and where the plant will go.
Note, foliage has a limit as you populate a scene.
So everything has a cap, believe it or not, is cool and as neat as Unreal is.
You can throw the kitchen sink at it, and you can still slow it down if you're not careful.
With too much foliage, you can bring your machine to a crawl, as you see here.
So you can get away with even putting cards in the distance, which have those alphas on
there, such as you can do like a large mountain, could be set on an alpha.
You can actually put a series of baked assets, foliage that is moving in the wind, on an
alpha in a flip book.
And you just have to determine how long that's on screen and where that cutoff point where
the loop is going to be.
Now when it comes to foliage for ICVFX, final pixel priority areas, it's very important
to consider some of these assets and how you want to handle them inside of the settings
themselves.
So we're going to actually take a look at that real quick.
One of the things you do want to turn on is evaluate world position offset.
You also want to make sure that your foliage is movable.
This prevents any super sampling that we have to cause any blurring.
And in the older versions of Lumen, this was a bigger problem.
If you didn't put it on movable, you would have definite blurring happening.
But right now, just for a precautionary measure, I like to turn it on and I think everyone
should because also you get the option if you want to eventually make it dynamic and
even control it in such a way so that there's wind and movement.
So it doesn't just look like a fake prop.
So in Unreal, let's go and jump in and we're going to go back to some of these settings.
We'll take a look at screen percentages as well as anti-aliasing, as well as that last
screen here where I show you how to address and to tweak and control some of the movability
as well as casting shadows.
Let's go and jump into Unreal and take a peek.
So in our scene here, let's go and switch to foliage.
So I'm going to go ahead and turn on foliage for a bit.
There we go.
In foliage, you'll see that we have a few settings that we can control.
Now we can make it so that we can paint on landscape, static meshes, or even a BSP.
If you're not familiar with BSP, it's kind of our old school low level, think of it as
an object.
You can actually turn a cube into a BSP if you needed, but there are also active BSPs
that you can use.
So you can actually paint on those too if you want.
You can even paint on other foliage if you want to and anything that's translucent.
So that option is there too.
So I'm going to go ahead and select this and shift select all my foliage for a moment.
And I'm going to turn them on.
This allows me now to paint wherever and whatever I want to based on that tick box in there.
Any of the settings that you create in each one of your foliage is, foliage is, if that
is such a word, you can actually go in here and save those if you change them.
Now let's go and just pick on one of these for now.
We'll just pick on this guy here.
So in here, we can choose our density, how much density we want to have, say 300 or so.
Then it shows that we can save it.
And I'll go and get rid of this guy here or put it back to default.
We can choose the radius.
We can choose the unit if we want it uniform or if we want to make them a little bit more
free as well as be able to lock down or change those values when it comes to the scale and
size.
At any time you can actually hit the marquee boxes here to be able to increase this is
similar to what you can do in Photoshop and ZBrush.
So you can actually go in here and close those down.
So you'll go down here, you'll see an alignment angle as well as a random yaw.
But this is where we want to turn on our moveable.
You want to turn that on.
In there we can choose casting shadows, effects dynamic.
You want to actually turn that on too, indirect lighting, effects a distance field lighting.
So when you turn this on, you do got to keep in mind when it comes to lighting in general,
you can turn this on and that's fine.
The only thing is in your lights themselves, you need to make sure your directional light,
especially if you're grabbing something from the marketplace has has your mesh distance
fields on your other lights don't necessarily have to do that.
If you did do that with your other lights and turn on mesh distance field, you could
get some banding.
So just be careful of that.
So we can actually turn this off.
We should still be okay.
This is mainly a little bit leaning more towards our old baking method.
Why this is off, but you can actually turn that on if you're seeing something's not
quite rendering correctly.
Ours is doing pretty well right now, so we're okay.
So for the most part here, again, also if you're doing baking, and again, remember,
I'll be putting some baking nuggets into here into this, each one of these lectures, just
to remind you, so we're going to mainly focus on lumen, but we're also going to be talking
a bit about some baking.
So you can control your resolution for this particular resource if you wanted to, you
can do that here, or you can do that within the object itself.
Now you'll notice we have all these different aspects, there's even an advanced area where
we can cast shadows on two sided, you can control all of this and actually can be pretty
helpful.
Does it bloat the scene?
Not so much.
It's mainly the asset itself.
We're mainly controlling a bit of its look visually in our scene.
As you can see, there's even some light map control here, if you were to do some baking,
and casting shadows on two sides, that does make it a little bit more beefy when it comes
to that object.
But for the most part, Unreal's working pretty slim and lean and mean right now, which is
actually pretty cool.
Now again, you can bring things to a crawl.
I said that with a grain of salt, because if I went in here and started painting my foliage
everywhere, I can make things go really, really slow.
So in the case of ICVFX, what you want to do is you can actually go in here and just
literally find that asset.
And if you need to, let's go ahead and just find the folder for it.
Grab this mesh, open this up a little bit.
It's really cramped.
I wouldn't grab the component class.
We want to go to the actual asset.
And you can actually literally just drag it into your scene if you need to.
And there's no fear in doing that.
You can totally do that.
So you can do a combination of painting foliage, maybe in the background.
When things are up close, you can actually bring them closer to the scene and then you
can adjust them accordingly, maybe even make a duplicate.
So if you need to make it a little bit higher, the one thing I do want to emphasize too,
you also want to make things nanite as much as possible.
Let's go and minimize this for a second here.
And we'll go back to that asset itself.
So you'll notice also you can control placement.
Now in that placement, it really just depends how you want it to be in the world, where
you want it to set.
The default should work just fine.
But again, we give you the option to be able to control as much as you need in your scene.
You can say whether it has collision or not.
You can even control heck, even the channels in here for the lighting.
I like to do this in the asset itself, but you do have the option to do this here inside
of our foliage as we generate and paint them in the scene.
Now you'll see there's also virtual texturing.
So if you need to draw on that, you can.
That is covered a bit in our other classes, but I definitely want to point that out so
that you can know that you can be drunk with power and build this any way that you want.
You can also remove noise if it does persist, particularly when it comes to your final pixel.
So you can increase the screen percentage.
There's persistent flickering.
But keep in mind, this is more from Final Pixel, like I said.
And if you're going to LED wall, this may cause a hit performance, make things a bit
harder to work with.
So when rendering, punch in the console variable in our movie render queue, you'll see right
here.
You want to punch in r.screenPercentage200 to remove noise when rendering 4K output.
Now, warning, like I said earlier, it's the same thing if you're just going to wall versus
Final Pixel.
All of this can be VRAM intensive if you're not careful.
So increasing that rendering and tweaking these out can cause things to get a little
bit chunky if you're not careful.
To also remove noise, you can override anti-aliasing and set the spatial sample to 2 and temporal
sample count to 16.
So that's also an option in your movie render queue.
So if you're using LODs, you can also increase your frames per second.
We can decrease our polys on screen if you want to when you're using your LODs.
So just be careful with that.
Again, test it out before you commit.
So to unlock screen size, control turn off your auto compute LOD distance, which we talked
about in the previous class set.
And in the LOD settings, you can set foliage to a small prop to gain frames per second.
So that's also an option if you needed to.
Now remember, converting your foliage to nanite ahead of time, like I said, when using Lumen
is the best workflow for optimization.
Again, nanite works on a triangular basis versus your regular LODs.
And LODs will actually swap out geometry more on that asset itself.
What we're going to be doing when we're using nanite, it actually uses that triangle information
so we get more finite detail and it pulls up what is needed on that object in a more
finite control, which is pretty great.
So don't rule out nanites.
That's it with this video.
In the next video, we're going to talk a bit more about optimization.
Thanks again.